Harold got all fired up after the first
pick of the draft last night you back
jumped out of your chair didn't you HR
ha ha ha well I don't know about that no
it was I was surprised it didn't take
hunter green and you know it's just you
don't see a talent come along like this
very often I mean Dan the kid throws 102
miles an hour and he would have been a
first-round pick as a shortstop so to
pass on that pick it's very tough to to
do well explain this though because this
isn't like other drafts where if you
that if you don't it felt like there
were players who didn't want to go to
the Minnesota Twins that they were that
least one player two players that turned
down the opportunity be the number one
pick not wanting to go to the twins why
didn't
why don't players want to go to the
twins well I don't think it was a matter
of not wanting to go to the twins the
way the draft is in baseball it's it's a
compensation pool that really doesn't
make a lot of sense like for example you
might have 15 million dollars you get to
work with and I got 15
and so I'll instead of saying the slot
is a seven million dollar slot I'm
spending half my pull money I'll see if
I can get a guy that will take 4 million
then I can spend more money to get more
players and that's what the negotiation
at the top well what unter Green gonna
cost the Cincinnati Reds then Oh he's
not taking a discount I'm sure that he
got his uh whatever that slot is I don't
think he's taking a discount is there
any chance though that he doesn't play
for the Reds he's only 17 he's committed
to UCLA I know that that's your leverage
here but what are the odds that he'll go
to the Reds organization or opted to go
to UCLA no he's going to sign it what
happens most of these guys before the
team's pick them they know they're going
to get them you know long here we went
through the first 10 rounds of the draft
we had one kid turned down his offer
everybody else signed so sign ability
that's pretty handled before team's pick
a guy because of what we're talking
about with the amount of pool money they
have and here's the question we had the
Dennis and I were talking about this
prior to will we see a day where
you have somebody who's able to play in
the field but also be lets say a
starting pitcher hunter green you know
Brendan McKay of Louisville those are
those are guys her two-way players do
you can use why would I take this guy
out of the lineup or why would I take
him off the mound if I think he can help
me every single day well the interesting
thing to me could we see it probably
more so now than ever before and here's
why because the pitch count is so
prevalent I mean you think about it we
only have a few select guys that are
throwing a hundred pitches in the major
leagues as it is yeah that was the
complexity for me with hunter green and
Brennan McKay so why am I going to have
one pick and say I want this guy he's
going to throw 70 pitches in one week
when he can be an impact guy that can
affect 150 games so I think with the low
pitch counts they may have the
opportunity to pull that off somebody
can throw 50 pitches right yeah I mean
why not it may not be able to starter
but we may see a guy come in the bullpen
and still go back to this position in
play so it depends it's tough to do but
we may get to that point someday yeah
that's what I thought if you're playing
first base and there were a lot of first
baseman's drafted in the first round if
you go from first base you come in you
got middle relief you face two or three
guys maybe an inning that you can go
back to first base
just seems like why it feels like these
these guys are major leaguers as a
pitcher and they're major leaguers as a
hitter why not combine both of those and
that feels like it's a rarity there so
well we've seen Joe Matt try to do it
with with a few his guys already and
they're not even to the couch yeah those
guys have position players so we'll see
he's a Harold Reynolds Major League
Baseball Network analyst the Oregon
State pitcher Luke Heimlich sexually
assaulted a six-year-old girl when he
was 15 this just came up the Portland
Oregonian did a lot of you know
backstory deep dive on this to find out
about this I guess he's a first round
talent which is that fair to say and
what is his future in Major League
well you know I don't know if he's the
first round talent he's definitely a top
five around talent okay and you know
he's helping Oregon State lead them to
the College World Series right now it's
one of those tough dynamics I don't know
if anybody's going to touch this kid and
I can understand why not and I can see
on the other side why somebody else be
pulling for him so that's a tough one
yeah just trying to understand that that
how this came out
and then how the teams deal with this if
you know he was punished or he had to
you know do pay his debt or whatever it
might be so understanding
you know how good is he and is a team
going to take a chance on us but you
think he's more of a you know fourth or
fifth round draft pick than a first or
second yeah I think today will tell you
a lot because today we go from rounds
three to ten and then tomorrow from ten
to forty and then the drafts over so I
think if he goes today then you got a
story and I think that's what everybody
will probably be talking about where did
Aaron judge come from my County Central
listen to this story Fresno State
University right so when Aaron was in
high school he was playing football and
I remember he was one of the guys I was
assigned to during the draft that year
he got drafted and he went to a football
camp at Fresno State and they were
touring the campus and he said hey can I
take some swings and baseball teams out
there so he took some swings and the
baseball coach said you got a
scholarship that's how I ended up on the
baseball team at Fresno State Oh crazy
right yeah but look at these numbers now
I mean he's leading the Yankees in every
offensive category and as a rookie right
doesn't make sense here well it doesn't
make sense in a way that the numbers are
ridiculous but the talent was always
there and and here's the difference that
people don't understand with the
Baseball Draft this is not like hey I'm
drafting Lonzo ball and he's going to
play for the Lakers tomorrow maybe turn
their fortunes around we're talking
about these guys we drafted last night
hunter green and etc
we may not see for four year yeah so
here's a guy who gets drafted he's
already 22 years old he goes to the
minors for three years and so he's got a
lot of time to work on that swing and
what he's done is refined it the power
was always there he just swung and
missed too much and he really changed
his swing over the last three years
where it started getting shorter and
shorter
he took away the leg kick he's got a
little bit of a swing now and for him it
was if he made contact he was going to
hit homeruns and right now he's making
contact but but I've seen in the last
week the the Boston Red Sox kind of
exploited him it started busting him up
high he couldn't catch up to the high
heater and then Baltimore comes in and
starts throwing balls down low again he
hits one 495 feet so I want to see if
the league adjust to him and how he'll
have to adjust to them but wasn't he up
part of trade rumors last year well yeah
you know sometimes you get lightning in
a bottle I mean I'll take the Yankees
expected this to happen no they were
going to treat him but the best thing
that happened to him though is Joe
Girardi saw something in him and you got
to just have one guy and Joe when he can
the spring training said I don't want to
trade this guy we're going to make him
compete and Aaron went in there knowing
that he's not given anything he was one
of the coveted talents that they had but
he had to compete the spring training
and then Joe Girardi came to him and
said it's your job don't worry about
anything just play and for a guy to here
that has been battling the whole time I
cleared his mind what's the longest home
run you ever saw in person Willie Mays
Aikens hit a ball in Seattle and in the
kingdom we had five decks and in the
left and right field be the third fourth
fifth deck and he hit one down the
walkway now I'll go into some folklore
but it's true because I was standing
there all right so Bo Jackson when he
first came to league everybody be like
you gotta watch go take batting practice
I remember George George Brett pulling
us outs and you got to watch this guy so
they come to Seattle after you've been
the league's
and he'd be talking trash to me all the
time you you know switch-hitter Reynolds
you you can switch it stuttering and
joking with me and it finished his round
of hitting and then he turned around
left-handed and he hit a ball up there
or Willie Mays Aikens hit a ball in the
game and I and my ten years playing in
the dome those the only two guys ever
saw a ball hit that far and he flipped
the bat down and walked out to you know
switch hitters if Bo would have just
played baseball well we'd be talking
about legendary stuff I mean he would
have hit balls like we're seeing now the
speed was incredible he would have done
things that we'd be still talking about
I mean that was that was what he did in
the little step that he played so as you
got better and started to make more
contact and started hitting 320 instead
of 260 it would have been beyond our
thinking I'll leave you with this I'll
give you the Yankees and the Nationals
or you can have the field for the World
Series Wow Yankees in the Nationals huh
yeah ah they're gonna have to get
through the Astros I still think the
Stroh's are going to go get pitching and
they're the best offense in baseball but
we'll see if they get the pitching you
like the nets
I like that pick right but but you think
it will be the Astros in the nationís if
I gave you Astros Nationals of the field
you're taking Astros national oh yeah
yeah I take that no I take that
tell the boys we set alone it was a good
watch I was flipping back and forth
watching the draft last night gives us
up thanks man yeah miss bombers yeah
yeah no I'm watching you when you
reacted to the twins first-round pick
and first number-one pick and you're
like you know I don't know if this is
the best shortstop out there no you know
that you big they were a surprise you
said it's going to change the draft it
did I thought it did I thought it
changed the order we'd heard about right
he ended up going to the Braves they had
thought no chance he was going to get
the hit to them the order was kind of
switched you know how you get these
mock drafts and you get a pretty good
idea where guys might fall yeah I
thought we saw a lot of shifting and it
changed the first realm no doubt about
just telling you I'm watching I'm
keeping an eye on you Chuck you are
dynamite I appreciate it I brother I'll
talk to you thank you thank me alright
and by the way just remember I'm not
damply sack I thought about Beckett that
was so funny when you drop the DPI you
know I'm here please I called it then
you responded I'm going he he must not
know this is me because I'm responding
to something you're saying on mage you
know Baseball Tonight there yeah yeah I
did not know it was you and then I got
home later and I was like explains that
you go all I thought that was please
sack yeah tell the boys to be subtle oh
thanks HR your legendary and please sack
trying to get there say that was kind of
like wow he'll never go lesson he'll
never get to me he'll never get me not
getting yellow he through solid
left-hander through salad but to think
of the NBA Finals I don't have any song
any I don't have any time I got a go HR
oh man I'll listen you get high
that's HR Harold Reynolds MLB tonight
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience